the situation is less bad than it
otherwise could be of course if
inflation were still in the double
digits but prices are still going up and
they're going up at a much higher rate
than the bank of England is supposed to
be targeting so come the end of the year
come next year people may still feel
worse off um I mean I suppose the
glimmer of good news here is that
average wages excluding bonuses do now
outpace inflation but that's only been
happening for a few months and it's only
about 1
1.5% so you know people might feel like
they can just about pay their bill in a
more comfortable way but nobody's
sitting around feeling especially Rich
because of this news that the government
has haded inflation the other difficulty
of course is that critics are going to
point out that um this is not really in
the government's remit uh Rishi cak's
number one priority uh was something
that is ultimately determined by the
bank of England because they have the
tools to bring inflation down and that's
mainly interest rates and those 14
consecutive interest rate hikes those
painful hikes have largely contributed
to why inflation is haved